untamed power
and beyond that
something special i
[Music]
think that it helped because i wasn't
trying to make her a character that i
thought she should be like Star Wars is
such a huge thing and so many people
love it and there's so many iconic
characters and I remember feeling free
of sort of trying to be anything I mean
obviously you still get nervous because
you want it so badly and I love this
character so much
but yeah because I hadn't grown up with
it and had it washed it like every day
of my life I was able to kind of do what
I wanted with her which I think was a
gift
[Music]
you know you're just so shocked I I was
like guys I am still having trouble
believing that I'm here and doing this
right now so uh I know when I
immediately found out like I was quiet
for so long I just couldn't grasped my
head around it and so I went back to my
day job and I didn't even I was still
just in disbelief if that makes any
sense so it was kind of easy not to tell
anyone because I was like this is all a
dream
I
[Music]
don't know there was one single person I
wanted to me I think that they had
experience in itself the cast is so
amazingly talented I mean from dating
John and Oscar to Donal and Gwendolyn
and Laura and Benicio and Adam and every
single person Andy Serkis well the best
part for me was that I sort of was given
these golden keys people just let me
walk around the set which is it's on
such lockdown that that is almost
impossible so even the days that I
wasn't working I was able to go to set
and watch everyone work it was a pretty
out-of-body experience
because they're just so
normal and open and welcoming and I
feel like it let me sort of be myself if
that makes any sense I think there's a
lot of expectation when you go into
something like this and you're the new
person and you're nervous and
seeing them just be themselves to me was
the most freeing thing I
became really good friends with marks
daughter Chelsea and we I would go over
to Mark's place and watch movies with
their families on the weekends because I
didn't have any friends over there so
yeah it was awesome and then I became
good friends with Carrie's daughter
Billie as well
[Music]
purchased many I've gone to target by
myself and bought them and no one even
notices me it's really great
Skywalker brave Princess Leia
courageous r2d2 a beep rose Oh
funny pork
adorable Chewbacca
kylo ren's terrifying
[Music]